Marvel Studios generally runs a pretty tight
ship when it comes to spoilers, with one big
exception: Spider-Man star Tom Holland, who
has become known as a bit of a spoiler machine.
So it's no surprise that information has started
to come out about Spider-man's next big screen
solo adventure.
Here's a look at every Spider-Man: Far From
Home rumor and spoiler leaked so far.
Spider-man: Field Trip
In late May of 2018, a rumor with some specific
details surfaced on Reddit, posted by a user
named "A Harbinger Of Stuff."
Citing only a "reliable source," it offered
a breakdown of the Homecoming sequel that
included Peter Parker traveling to London
for some kind of conference, Mysterio as the
main villain, Scorpion and Vulture in minor
roles, and the introduction of Alistair Smythe,
a.k.a. the Spider Slayer in the Marvel comics.
Among other details, the user claimed there
would be an MI6 agent in the film named Jessica
Drew, a name comics fans will recognize as
the secret identity of the original Spider-Woman.
"And this is Jessica Drew, who, as a child
while visiting her father's laboratory, was
bitten by a poisonous spider!"
Though many of these rumors are still unconfirmed,
several do line up with what we know about
the film.
One detail that has been proven wrong, though,
is the name of the movie.
Marvel Studios head honcho Kevin Feige explained
in an interview with io9 that the name Spider-Man:
Far From Home was chosen in part because of
the film's international flavor.
"We shoot a lot of films in London but there’s
another reason we’re shooting in London
which is, yes, Spidey, of course, will spend
some time in New York, but he’ll spend some
time in other parts of the globe."
Matt or Jake
In May 2018, reports surfaced that Jake Gyllenhaal
was set to play Spidey villain Mysterio in
the second Sony/Marvel Studios Spider-Man
film, though in June, Feige clarified that
Gyllenhaal's involvement wasn't actually confirmed
yet.
Gyllenhaal was reportedly the second big actor
rumored to be in talks to play a Spidey villain.
According to Meet the Movie Press, Matt Damon
was approached by Marvel, but ultimately passed.
Too bad, because based on his previous experience
as a supervillain, it would have been epic.
"This control activates my atomic bomb, which
can destroy the entire Earth"
Old friends
According to Variety, Michael Keaton's Vulture
isn't done with Peter Parker just yet.
Keaton's reportedly set to reprise his role
as the villain, who'll be working alongside
Mysterio in Spider-Man: Far from Home.
The report doesn't say how prominently Vulture
will be featured, but it's already fueled
speculation that the films are building toward
an introduction of the Sinister Six.
Vulture isn't the only Homecoming alumnus
reported to return.
We're also expecting to see Marisa Tomei as
Aunt May, Zendaya as MJ, Jacob Batalon as
Peter Parker's best bud Ned Leeds, and director
Jon Watts behind the camera.
Smoove Operator
In July 2018, Deadline reported that actor
and comedian J.B.
Smoove had joined Spider-Man: Far from Home's
cast in an unspecified leading role.
Considering he's best known for his comic
turns in Curb Your Enthusiasm and films like
Hall Pass, though, chances are he's going
to bring the humor to whatever role he plays.
And hey, he already knows exactly what a superhero
sidekick's role is.
"Little emotional service doggies that lick
your face and make you feel good about yourself
mmm mmm and they tinkle all over your shirt
and they're so happy to see you and makes
you feel good inside"
Another MCU character
In June 2017, The Hollywood Reporter said
that another already established hero would
be joining Spider-Man in Far from Home, but
it wouldn't be his MCU mentor Iron Man.
So who is it?
Well, back in 2017, director Jon Watts told
ScreenRant he'd love to see Spidey team up
with Black Widow.
"I like to think of what he could learn from
Black Widow, but then I think he would be
too nervous to even get a single word out."
We do know who it won't be, though, as Slashfilm
asked Fiege if Doctor Strange would be guest-starring.
"I could be coy about it, but no."
Dates to remember
Far from Home's July 5th, 2019 arrival, only
two months after Avengers 4, puts it in an
interesting spot.
Its relation to Avengers 4 suggests it'll
be much more defined by its position in the
MCU than its predecessor.
Not only does it kick off Phase 4, but producer
Amy Pascal said in June 2017 that Far from
Home opens "a few minutes" after the resolution
of Avengers 4, suggesting Pete will still
be dealing with the aftermath of the battle
against Thanos.
And Fiege backed that up, telling io9,
"The way Civil War […] informed Homecoming,
the two Avengers films that precede [Far From
Home] will greatly inform [...] the next movie."
A new suit?
Spider-Man: Homecoming costume designer Louise
Frogley may have unintentionally dropped a
spoiler that Peter Parker will be taking a
new costume into battle during Spider-Man:
Far From Home.
Though she isn't actually working on Far from
Home, she told IndiaWest,
"The costumes will have very big changes because,
in the film, Spider-Man becomes more like
a man and not a teenager."
So does she have some kind of inside information
even though she's not working on the film?
Hmm.
Taking control of the story
When Tom Holland "leaked" the title of Spider-man:
Far From Home on his Instagram account, it
seemed like yet another slip-up from Marvel's
fountain of spoilers.
"What I do know is I've got the new script,
I'm super excited to read it, and...it's gonna
be great!
So ya, Spider-Man 2, let's do this!"
But Feige told Birth.Death.Movies that it
was completely intentional.
"There are certain logistics of the way these
movies are made that meant that title would
potentially be leaked in some way because
it was going out into the world in various
forms.
So Mr. Holland took it upon himself to leak
it for us."
You know what they say about spoilers: with
great power comes great responsibility.